hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well letter 66 Seneca
is examining some important issues
within stoic ethics that are often not
all that well understood and he's
explaining them to his interlocutor Luke
Ilyas and thereby - to us now he begins
the letter by talking about running into
a childhood you could say friend and
also a classmate and he tells us a few
things in here that are important for
shadowing for what's going on within the
letter he tells us that he's begun to
see his friend caranas in a new way
he seems handsome to me and as upright
in stature as he is in spirit and and
what does he you know bringing that up
for well Clarence is as old as Seneca is
and his body isn't in great shape so
this is a prime example of something
that is from the stoic perspective
indifferent the body being made
beautiful and good by the mind or the
soul which is virtuous which is one of
the things we're gonna be talking about
in this letter the other thing is he
brings up this conversation that he and
Claire honest were having as a pretext
for introducing these ideas to us he
tells us our topic for discussion was
this how can all good
be equal to one another if they are of
threefold status if there's three kinds
of goods and he tells us that there
there's there's these are both stoic
positions right there's three main kinds
of goods and you might say well okay
I'll go with you on that let's see what
the Stoics you have to say and we'll
come back to those in just a moment but
then the first part you might say whoa
wait a second here
how can all goods be equal who said that
they were equal well
the Stoics did because that is one of
their main commitments about the nature
of the genuine good they're not saying
that everything that everybody considers
to be good or equal as a matter of fact
they think that most people have
fundamentally mistaken ideas about
what's actually good and what's bad and
what's within this realm of what we call
the indifferent and this indeed is
something that many people had a hard
time accepting it's what we call one of
the stoic paradoxes that all good things
are equal and you know likewise all bad
things are equal as well and you might
say well how can that possibly be
you know nobody else says things like
that do they not even the other virtue
ethicists like the plaintiffs or
Aristotelian czar Epicureans they seem
to think that there's multiple kinds of
goods and the Stoics say well insofar as
they're good no but then you might say
well why are you talking about there
being three kinds of goods so Seneca
lays this out for us and he tells us
what are these three kinds of goods
primary secondary and tertiary and in
the Latin it's just that you know primo
segunda tarantia meaning you know for a
second third oftentimes these would be
framed in terms of a hierarchy of values
and indeed we can talk about the
tertiary Goods as being in some sense
below the other goods in a way that
we'll see in just a few minutes let's
talk about the primary Goods what are
the examples that he provides well he
gives us several right here Joe
why peace the safety of one's homeland
if we look a little bit further down he
when he's talking about the principal
good and the mind that gazes at what is
real knows what to pursue and to avoid
assigns value to things in accordance
with nature the spirit that injects
itself into the cosmos as a whole all
those sorts of things those are all
primary Goods right and then we have the
secondary goods what are those well
here's some examples endurance under
torture self-control during serious
illness we might think about battlefield
courage as another prime example of this
nobody unless they're you know totally
unreasonable or they're following
wrongheaded desires is going to seek out
a conflict but once you're actually in
conflict in order to protect other
things that you do consider to be good
like say your freedom or the you know
protecting your country or protecting
justice or something like that you will
put yourself in risk of bodily harm
bodily harm is not a good thing by
itself right nor is risking things a
good thing by itself
but he talks about these secondary goods
as being manifested in unfortunate
material that is they take place when
the things that we're dealing with are
not optimal and may in fact be quite bad
in many ways it's not good to get sick
right it's not the calamity that a lot
of people think it is but it's
definitely not something good and it
imposes hindrances and harms upon you
have certain sorts certainly to your
body and therefore it requires some sort
of response that's a good response
barring illness in the way that one
ought to what about these Terry Goods
let's think about his examples he says a
modest walk a calm and dignified facial
expression gestures befitting an
intelligent person you know these we
might not be able to relate to entirely
we might want other kinds of
box or other kinds of facial expressions
a lot of these are culturally determined
you could say but there are appropriate
actions and inappropriate actions the
way that the Stoics conceived of that
sort of thing in Greek they called those
Cafe matzah and in in Latin they called
them a thick um sometimes these are
translated as duties or things as being
contrary to duty but there is this
general idea that in all sorts of things
like if you're gonna wear a tie for
example well you should tie it in a
certain way I mean I could loosen it and
be more casual if I'm trying to you know
show that I'm a cool guy who doesn't
take the the rules very seriously or I
can also tighten it up to show another
sort of thing a seriousness about the
thing that we're studying there's lots
of ways right and so each of these is
understood as being a certain kind of
good sonica tells us that primary goods
are chosen unconditionally we say those
are good things we want those we choose
those we pursue those secondary Goods
are chosen when necessary you don't
choose to endure torture for the sake of
enduring torture if you do from a stoic
perspective you're misguided and
imprudent and vicious likewise
you know with the tertiary Goods they're
chosen in some sort of sense they're
chosen perhaps we might say when they
are convenient or befitting convinient
er by the way in Latin means you know it
fits the occasion it fits the
circumstances so he goes on and he
provides us with a little bit of context
here by talking about and thinking about
the supreme good he says let's go back
to the principal or supreme good
consider what kind of thing it is I just
brought this up a few minutes ago the
spirit or mind the Animus that gazes at
what is real that knows what to pursue
and to avoid that assigns value to
things in accordance with nature and not
by opinion the spirit that injects
itself into the cosmos as a whole and
cast its contemplation over every action
of the universe the spirit that attends
equally to thought in action that great
and forceful spirit
not vanquished by adversary' adversity
nor again by the blandishments of
prosperity that does not yield itself to
either but rises above all contingency
all accident that most beautiful spirit
well marshaled and grace and likewise
and strength sound in sober tranquil and
undismayed that spirit that no power can
subdue no chance event can elevate or
depressed
that's quite a pan dry right there isn't
that running through the entire
paragraph what is that spirit what is
that mind virtue that's what virtue is
virtue allows us to have all those sorts
of things virtue embodies itself in all
those sorts of things so virtue is what
the primary good is what the good that
is making other things good is for the
Stoics and he goes on and he says okay
now if we understand it this way then we
have to acknowledge certain things about
virtue he says that virtue takes on
multiple aspects right and so you know
we might think about the the cardinal
virtues that the Stoics in fact
distinguish seneca doesn't go into that
too much here but it's lurking in the
background wisdom justice temperance and
courage each of those is a kind of
virtue right and each of those is virtue
each of those by the way has other
virtues under it as well so so you know
courage includes the kind of courage
that stands up to fear but it also
includes endurance of hardship right and
justice doesn't just include following
the rules or fulfilling one's pledges it
also includes beneficence or benevolence
being good to other people right so a
virtue takes on multiple aspects and it
does so in relation to what gets
translated typically as conditions or
circumstances in in the Latin it's you
know the term grace which just means
thing or affair and it's usually in the
plural
this discussion so within you know
different frameworks within different
situations in relation to different
things we exercise virtue in different
ways but it still remains the same
virtue according to Seneca and according
to the Stoics he says virtue is is not
permitted to retreat it becomes neither
less nor more it's transformed first
into one quality that into another
shaped according to the condition of the
things it's about to do he's got this
wonderful phrase here that I very much
like he says whatever it touches it
attracts and tinctures with its own
likeness it adorns actions friendships
sometimes entire households which is
entered and put into order whatever it
handles it makes loveable remarkable
admirable so virtue takes the let's call
it raw material of life and transforms
it into virtuous stuff right so the
virtue isn't any greater lesser in doing
so the material may be more or less
suitable for that but the virtue remains
the same and he goes on and he says it's
its power its magnitude cannot increase
any more if only because that which is
greatest has no augmentation when a
thing is right you will find nothing
more right anymore than a thing can be
truer than what is true or more
temperate that then what is temperate
every virtue is the limit and a limit as
it has a fixed measurement and so you
might say well that goes against our
ordinary experience one person can be
more temperate than another and and
Seneca you know could respond by he
doesn't here by saying well the raw
material is different right that guy
over there who has terrible habits and
is struggling to you know not have his
tenth serving at the buffet the wedding
that he's he's attending stuffing
himself so much that he has to undo his
belt buckle at his pants I think third
the villages if he actually does
exercise temperance
the temperance that he's exercising is
just as much as the temperate temperance
of the super temperate person according
to Seneca and that may be a little bit
counterintuitive he tells us a little
bit later that each virtue is equal to
each other says human virtues come under
a single rule right reason itself is
single and uniform
so the virtues are equal to each other
as our here's another key thing the
deeds or the actions of virtue and all
persons who possess the virtues and
again this is rather counterintuitive
and probably you know requires more of a
justification than he's actually
providing here and the Stoics do in fact
treat this quite a bit
now here's another point that he's going
to make over and over and over again in
this if anything could add to or
diminish virtue then virtue itself would
be would be lacking there would be a
problem there a kind of deficit he says
if matters external to virtue either
diminish or augment it then what is
honorable ceases to be the sole good if
you concede that then the honorable
ceases to exist altogether and he's got
a really interesting point here that
makes him almost sound a little proto
conscious well or Abelard e'en or any
anyone else who is really stressing the
importance of motive he says everything
that is honorable is voluntary mingle it
with any reluctance any complaint any
second thoughts any fear and it loses
its best feature it is no longer self
determined so he says if a person
refuses something complains or thinks
that is bad then he is disturbed in
Welters and grievous conflict on one
side rectitude appears and summons him
on the other harm is suspected and
causes him to withdraw so he's going to
provide a lot of examples that we don't
need to go into in great detail about
why it is that virtue has to be the same
all virtuous acts all virtues all
virtuous people what we're really
interested in here is more the upshot
for the three kinds of goods that he's
going to discuss here so he's going to
frame this in relation to another key
idea of the Stoics that again he's sort
of assuming some some background
knowledge of on the audience's part he's
not going to argue for or explain in
great depth and detail here but he's
going to discuss elsewhere and that is
being in accordance with nature or being
against nature or contrary to nature so
the Latin for that is secundum naturae
--m and the you know opposite of that is
contra not total and those are the the
words that he's using here so this is a
really important stoic idea we do have
to explain this a little bit to be in
accordance with nature doesn't just mean
to simply accept how things work out
mechanically within the universe it also
means to be in accordance with what you
might call our best nature our human
nature as fully developed which is not
really the case in any of us we can we
can be more fully developed or less
fully developed but there is sort of
this ideal and it's often talked about
in terms of the sage or the wise person
who would be fully realized right and we
can we can use that as kind of a model
in Seneca does that so the three kinds
of goods he says the primary secondary
and tertiary are on a par right what
that means is that they're going to be
in equality you could say in equal so
they're there in some way on the same
level how so well he talks about this a
little
later on and there is some stuff I want
to come back to here he says that the
primary goods so for example having
virtue being free having joy having
peace all those sorts of things are in
accordance with nature so when we're
experiencing them we are when we're
pursuing them were actually you could
say connected with with how things ought
to be we're in a greater communication
with the universe as such right and
that's all fine right that's pretty
straightforward
he also tells us though that secondary
goods things like showing well really
almost everything concerned with
fortitude or courage the one of the
cardinal virtues and a lot of things
concerned with justice and quite frankly
a lot of things concerned of temperance
these are in a some respect contrary to
nature they're contrary to nature
because their material is contrary to
nature they're not things that we want
so being sick for example you know
having things going on in your body that
actually do to some degree affect your
mind depending on how you allow them to
that is contrary to nature it's not it's
not being in a good state health is you
know in accordance with nature disease
is contrary to nature not in the moral
sense but in the sense of not being you
know not being good for it's very
difficult to avoid this word good and
bad right but our actions our choices
the things that we do in relation to
these obstacles these challenges these
these things that we face that is in
accordance with nature so it's both in
and
in accordance with nature and contrary
to nature what about the tertiary Goods
well here Seneca doesn't really carry on
the conversation that well and I think
he's assuming that his readership
already knows about this sort of stuff
for the Stoics all these sorts of things
that we consider to be largely
indifferent and don't produce great
obstacles for us but could go one way or
could go the other you know like my tie
do I have it loose or do I have it tight
how do I walk do I make an attempt to
enunciate properly order I'll come on
clear my words like this because I'm
being liturgy
right all those are basically
indifferent but they could be good or
bad and in some minor cells depending on
how virtue is using them so let's take
the last example if I'm slurring my
words and my goal is actually to
communicate to you something about stoic
philosophy which presumably if I was a
stoic I'd care about right I want the
audience to actually understand that
then speaking in a sloppy way would it
actually be something bad not bad in the
sense like you know I'm destroying
people's minds or something like that
but you know it's it's not good and
speaking in a clear way would be
something good recording this in a
fairly quiet environment rather than
right next to the train tracks that's
probably in the class of the tertiary
Goods and now are the contrary to nature
in accordance with nature they're in
accordance with nature but there you
could say in a lesser way than the
primary goods so insofar as their goods
at all they're all in accordance with
nature but they're in accordance with
nature in different ways and insofar as
their Goods they're all connected with
virtue you might say well what about the
tertiary Goods well you can use them in
the right way use them in accordance
with justice use them in accordance with
temperance use them particularly in
accordance with wisdom that's part of
the backdrop here in Senate
because point of view and the points
that he's trying to make now he finishes
this up with a very interesting
discussion about a guy who is a great
hero to the Romans and here he's gonna
make a case he actually says that if any
Goods could be greater than others I
would have given preference to those
Goods more than the others I'd have said
that the harsh ones are greater than the
soft luxurious kind beating down ones
difficulties is greater than governing
ones delights why well because in a
certain sense you can tell that you're
really virtuous when you have to
struggle right not just when you're
enjoying the fruits of virtue and
everything's going along just fine so he
talks about moose yes right now moose
iasts went into the camp of one of the
the enemies of Rome this is in the early
days to show him how to show the king
how tough Romans were he stuck his hand
into a brazier filled with red-hot coals
and stood there with his hand burning
away until poor Cestius ordered them to
take the brazier away it was like point
made right that took incredible
fortitude right so Seneca is looking to
that sort of example I don't know that
we should go too far along that path
with them the main point is that what
he's making here saying that if all the
virtues are on an equal nature these
three types of good therefore are on
this par or on equality and we can
connect them all together so that is
Senecas presentation of this very
important topic in stoic ethics that
involves genuine paradox all goods are
actually the same unless we consider
them from certain perspectives
you